musk and Zuckerberg embrace the idea of
punching each other's face
yeah it's Twitter versus meta to see
which billionaire is better
Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg have
agreed to settle their online rivalry in
a real world cage match to the death
[Music]
how did that last part but it's
featuring more nerd on nerd violence
than someone cutting the line at
Comic-Con earlier this week Elon took
issue with Meadows reported development
of an app that will directly compete
with Twitter see how nerdy this is
sharing his displeasure in a tweet
thread Elon challenged Zuck to Slug It
Out in person writing quote I'm up for a
cage match if he is LOL
now we have yet to find out who law is
uh is LOL like I don't know does he
identify as law we don't know Zuckerberg
then commented on Instagram quote send
me location
yeah are they feuding or flirting of
course a lot of people thought it was
all a joke but UFC president Dana White
says he spoke to both parties and
they're dead serious as long as Elon can
pass his drug test for Oz Epic
musk even tweeted his enthusiasm at
having Joe Rogan referee as long as he
can pass his drug test for horse pills
I'm joking
that was a lie perpetrated by CNN it was
Ivermectin which is a drug that is
regularly used by billions of people
see how I corrected myself maybe you'd
learned something from that audience
a couple of things to consider elon's 51
he's taller and heavier and Zuck is only
39 and trained martial artist currently
competing in Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
he even won a tournament earlier this
year I wish we had a picture but we
don't
so it looks like it's happening right
and it could very well be the biggest
fight of all time but it's this kind of
behavior considered childish childish is
it what we want from our wealthy class I
haven't seen this level of billionaire
violence it's Oprah beat the battle
Warren Buffett
Pete I I kind of like the idea of
settling public disputes with cage
matches how about you I love it yeah you
do uh do you really believe that Mark
Zuckerberg is a trained Jiu Jitsu
fighter who won a tournament I mean did
he pick his opponents I don't know and
you all know that guy who's like oh I'm
training a jiu jitsu yeah I'm Legit I
got a belt it's like 10 seconds into an
actual bout it's all out the window it
has no skills I mean dyrus I'm looking
at tires the guy who knows we have an
old saying everyone's got a plan to get
hit in the mouth and once you get hit in
the mouth
uh you know what we're sexist
understanding all the usually
comes out of you or you'll man up one or
the other you either get hit and go on
an apology tour or you knuckle up and
let's go
I feel like this is a double apology
tour but
I'm team musk on this one I'm gonna go
you think he wins I would go I will go
with Elon a matter of fact let's make it
let's make it sexy Winner Takes all
Facebook versus Twitter Instagram you
get the company you get the company and
you also get his kids yes
[Laughter]
it's the government's kids I literally
brought my kids to the government they
still wouldn't take them
the fullest propaganda
but I'm team musk I'd be in this corner
I'm too uh there's no I have no reason
for it I just looking at the two I feel
like he's got it but I feel like we
didn't have to break it up after 30
seconds yeah well no it depends because
it would take four to five minutes
before they actually land any contact on
each other because they'll just be
waving around like this
because they have like they both have
are nearsighted yeah so we so it's just
like where are you all right Aaron who
do you think is going to win and why I
actually do think that Zuckerberg would
win because I did the research and
apparently he is trained and there are
photos from the fight and his his person
and his person his person went on the
record and said that he has been
training in this but musk for his part
said that his training would be his move
called the whale where he would just lay
on top of Zuckerberg and see how that
goes I mean this could be like The
Reincarnation of like Celebrity Death
Match that claymation show from the 90s
where we could have like two Titans of
Industry just battle it out for you know
charity or whatever I mean it doesn't
have to end in death but that was you
know the premise of the cartoon show
back in the night yeah but we can dream
um I built do believe there was a
celebrity boxing reality show wasn't
there a cat you're the expert did they
have it was like people like Anson
Williams versus Scott Baio you know
Danny bonaducci you know versus the Octo
mom
remember the Octo Mom amazing she had
eight babies hence octo ah at once
something else
I don't remember that well you know what
you should I wish you would do more
research
on the questions I'm gonna ask you who
don't you excited
have you ever settled anything
physically no
no women don't do this yeah we are much
more civilized we just search for the
weaknesses of another person and then
tear them down emotionally yes
creating creating deep insecurities that
require years of therapy to undo
okay civilized people I have the reality
show
octo mom in the octogon
[Laughter]
no one's getting in that no
versus Joy but it's her versus her kids
yes now you're in how old are the kids I
don't know if they're like seven or
eight that's a good match yeah yeah
climbing all over
all right I guess I should move on since
I'm drifting into nonsense and my hand
movements
I think the octomom has tentacles that
is a good question
I would like to see like if I if we I
would like to see kilmead and a
man-eating lion
a really small cage
actually that could be the the
they'll be the main event and you guys
will be the mass before the main event
kill meat versus gut field Kill Me
versus gut yeah in a in a bull rope
match so they're tied to each other so
they can't get away from each other now
that'll be fun all right up next her
hair is bushy and her new job is Cushy
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else